love these Happy Endings I know right
it's [__] wonderful it's wonderful
not getting mad at Joe for saying this
is a dark Petty Revenge story huh yeah
I'm not because you you led me down the
road and I was like oh this is gonna be
fun this is gonna be ladies Corky
[Music]
all right this is a story
of petty Revenge nice these are the best
stories the best stories if only Steve
was here so this happened in India
basically what had happened was there
was a wedding and this bride you know
for whatever reason had her ex-lover
come to this wedding good because she's
a dumb [__]
that's the end of the story let's wrap
it up and we're done Fair diagnosis I
know dumb [__] like that guys and
girls I think that's a dumb [__] move
they just make stupid decisions you know
you don't think inviting your ex to your
wedding is a good idea that's a smart
move what if it's like a junior high and
then you're like I don't know like 29
now whoa were you good friends with them
you're high accident yeah you're gonna
waste your invite I just noticed there's
some people that are just really done
like that where they're like in a new
committed relationship like really
commit they really like this person they
still have their ex's number on their
phone
um I'm like you're just dumb you're just
asking for trouble yeah you're just like
putting sugar all over the house and
then when ants come oh what happened I
don't know
I'm like you're dumb dude
you're an idiot so this uh this ex-lover
you know comes to the wedding and gives
a wedding gift
the winner gift is a home theater music
system see the ants come and do the
[__] ants coming [__] and it's rig
with cameras it's rigged with explosives
when newlywed husband plugged it then
plugs it in him and his brother died
they just blew the [__] up actually four
people get injured including an 18 month
old child that suffered injuries dude
you made this article sound like it was
like fun and zany I literally started
with this is a petty Revenge story dude
Petty is not that's not Penny Petty it's
Petty it's not the exact definition
Petty Revenge nah that's Petty but you
should have said dark Petty that's
premeditated don't be angry with me
because somebody else was a dumb [__]
okay I just think that when he plugged
it in he probably had a slow-mo Indian
death like a Bollywood death with a lot
of music or 100 people came out started
dancing it was like and the music's slow
and then they're like super dramatic
yeah yeah that's probably what happened
see this is what happens this reminds me
of like you know back our our era there
would be like those Asian chicks that go
to the club and all of a sudden an hour
later full-on gang on gang Rumble
because the [__] chick be doing some
dumb [__] [__] pitting like her exit
that's an arrival game I don't even know
why she's dating fighting Jerry's
fighting fighting you would love these
cherries well no it's the Jerry's that
start the fight but really they step out
so all the guys have to come in and
they're like they're fighting over me
yeah and then Jerry's over there like
what's up full-on rumbles what happened
at Club school dances that's crazy
because a [__] stupid ass dumb Jerry
making moves
did this ever happen to you specifically
no I'm smart but I see that [__] happen
yeah and I'm like do you think she
invited him because she goes I'm gonna
make him jealous and then after he does
that she's like I don't know he was
gonna do that exactly it's one of those
situations exactly I've seen that go
down so many times you guys never had to
get in a fight for your girlfriends not
yet
uh I don't think so no hell no I ain't
doing no [__] I ain't doing that
why are you starting drama stop it I
don't think I even date chicks that are
dumb like that like if I see they have a
history of dumbness
your history of dumbness dude in high
school there were so many of these
things where like
um there was one time this girl she
wanted to get back at her ex because
they had some issues so she's she spread
this thing about how
um you know that guy assaulted her and
all that right so her guy friends the
group of guys she was with they were
like they were thugs like and they
[__] beat his ass so hard right and
then she was like shocked like why did
you do that like she thought what she
wanted was them to just gossip about it
and ruin his reputation they broke his
leg and it was like your friends are
gang members these guys like they shoot
at people like what did you think
they're gonna do like you thought they
were just gonna gossip and go oh let's
ruin this guy's rap and hurt his feet
like you know with gossip yeah with
gossip like and then I mean when your
stupid teenagers right like you just do
some stupid [__] but I remember things
like that went down there was another
one where a guy got actually
um
shot up at because there was some girl
drama that went down and then they went
to the park and then I think she
exaggerated like the level of like
like [__] talking or whatever and he was
just waiting in the car and a rival gang
came in and just shot him up yeah love
these Happy Endings I know right it's
[__] wonderful it's wonderful not
getting mad at Joe for saying this is a
dark Petty Revenge story huh yeah I'm
not because you you led me down the road
and I was like oh this is gonna be fun
this is gonna be easy Corky
I'm not a zany one for you the only time
that I had to get in the fight for like
a girl I was dating was like my first
girlfriend and um but the dude didn't
fight so thank God you didn't I would
have got my ass back but like it was it
uh you have to Bluff a little bit well
yeah because it was it was kind of funny
because I was 16 and we went to the um
we went to uh Santa Monica Third Street
Promenade and we were just like watching
all these like uh Street shows and stuff
and then you know like the crowd builds
up around it and things I might have
told you guys but um the crowd there was
like one of those weird guys that would
like push up on girls asses and like act
like he's just trying to see stuff yeah
so it's a good move it was like I can't
see yeah he did that to like my girl and
her friend and then they were like dude
this guy just like was like humping on
us so then I got behind him and I
started super humping him and then he
just he like turned around I was like
what the [__] I think he was so
embarrassed that we all knew yeah and
the whole crowd like looked yeah yeah
and then uh he didn't he didn't fight he
just ran away did you you humped that
guy yeah I thought I was gonna have to
fight him pump them into submission yeah
dude yeah but that wasn't because of a
dumb [__] that guy was a dumb [__]
yeah yeah and I don't know if there's
less of those guys now but I feel like
in the late 90s early 2000s there was a
shitload of those yeah there were and
then and then cell phone cameras were
invented yeah yeah and then guys started
humping them and then
that's how you stopped it was a [__]
epidemic there's so many guys he just
really thought about it I was like man I
should really think about like what I've
been doing to these ladies because I was
like yeah I changed his whole outlook
it's like I didn't realize it if
somebody did it to me how I would feel
yeah like that's not cool that guy was
like way bigger than me they would beat
my ass if we fought I would have got but
you helped him so you dominated him yeah
see that's a zany happy story yeah
that's zany yeah that is zany take some
of those what I'm not saying it's just
shot up you know what I mean
explosions yeah but you know it must
have been a quick explosion he's the one
who made it a slow explosion with a
dance and I've been so quick I can't
tell talk about it this is like a mafia
story no it's a Bollywood happy ending
with an explosion deck yeah all right
and it's pretty crazy to invite your ex
and not realize he has the potential to
make a bomb while still while still
receiving a home theater music system a
dumb [__] also who's using home theater
systems like that well maybe the whole
Community was like Taliban related you
know in India I mean like it's a
different country no it's a complete
different country but Osama was in
Pakistan and their neighbors oh [__] see
Joe knows more about geography than we
do that's the problem you're telling me
that Taliban don't have homies like in
other countries surrounding them I
thought they don't only exist in
Afghanistan that's such a like a
two-step process you're telling me that
Taliban don't follow somebody on social
media from a person that's in a country
next to a neighboring City
like well I guess they do that if I'm
the groom and my wife invites her ex
it's weird it's definitely weird but if
I'm the groom and I open up the gift and
I'm like holy [__] this guy's your
ex-boyfriend is so cool you got us homes
Studio system and you plug it in and you
explode but like you'll be really happy
right before that's kind of an advanced
bomb and way isn't it no like that [__]
didn't blow on the way home or nothing
like that's pretty good can you imagine
you're like hell excited to watch like
Avengers or something and Surround Sound
that's me you're just like whoa oh he's
so cool and then you're like get it
ready and you plug it every you're right
right about to plug it in it goes
humiliating thing because
he probably placed the speakers where he
wants them he spent the whole day
couches already he's got the lazy boy he
got a koozie he already put his old
sound bar on offer up he queues up rrr
and you know why the ex-boyfriend the
ex-boyfriend is smart too too because he
knows the guys are gonna get like
they're gonna be coming all over this
yeah because they're like we're gonna
[__] get surround sound we're gonna
watch this movie dude and that's why it
was him and his brother that's like
setting it up where was wifey not there
she was like I don't care yeah you know
I don't [__] care about this [__] yep
these explosion distance away for sure
what are they gonna do watch 90 Day
Fiance on surround sound they don't care
you can't watch TLC on surround ladies
don't watch TV when I turn on I'm like
babe let's watch the show as soon as we
turn it on she's like
and then it's sleeping isn't that kind
of like a little TV oh never mind mini
TV I wonder like what's what's the way
to get away with this like obviously
they were gonna know that the sound
system no I feel like he was trying to
kill all yeah really I thought he was
just trying to kill bit him so then when
she invites him to the funeral she could
be like who's only setting up a surround
sound by themselves well that's why the
brother died too no he he thought about
that he was the man will be blowing up
right well it's going in the house it
says the intensity of the blast was so
strong that it reportedly brought down
the roof and walls of the house oh when
you bring that roof and walls isn't that
the whole thing they should have known
when he opened it it's like whoa this is
a 20 speaker surround sound
this one's crazy but then you're like
whoa this guy's the man that's a great
gift there's a speaker everywhere holy
[__] yeah but we've been to India for
like you could like flick the wall
oh [__] that's part of the argument you
can flick any wall on a [__] explode
it's your flick though it's not our
flicks
you've been to India twice that's tight
no it's not
[Music]